another option you have for paid
marketing so directly by ad space from
websites or more easily from ad networks
there are some websites who can sell you
there and real estate directly but in
most cases you'll use an ad network or
an ad exchange platform to buy ad space
and target your audience in the most
relevant websites these networks are
using today's technological platforms
that allow both advertisers and
publishers to optimize their buy or sell
accordingly these platforms are called
DSP and SSP demand side platform and
supply side platform a demand-side
platform allows advertisers to engage in
transparent automated media buying
across multiple sources using unified
targeting data optimization and
reporting the platform helps the EDD
buyer to aggregate all this data and
find the most ideal impressions for a
campaign a supply-side platform helps
web publishers automate and optimize the
selling of their online media space
check out the instructor notes for a
great glossary